So, ich neige irgendwie zu auf die Enter-Taste, teilweise ein bisschen zu fest zu hauen.
Das mache ich auf der Arbeit auch, da haben sich auch schon mal ein paar Leute beschwert.
Da habe ich mich zusammen gerissen und jetzt habe ich Big Brain Move gemacht, ich habe
einfach Silikonringe unter meiner NumBlock Enter-Taste.
Ich habe mir für die Arbeit ja mal vor zwei Jahren oder so eine mechanische Tastatur
gekauft, weil die Notebook-Tastaturen und das, was die da hatten, so schlecht ist.
Da habe ich mir eine ordentliche Tastatur gekauft, die klackert halt ein bisschen und irgendwann
ich haue halt immer gerne die Enter-Taste und irgendwann hat sich mal einer beschwert,
Max, hau noch nicht immer so deine Tastatur, da habe ich mir so einen Pack Silikonringe
gekauft.
Es gibt extra Silikonringe für mechanische Tastaturen, für so Tastaturschläger.
Dein Interesse ist kaputt, feelsBatman, Alter, also bad, nicht bett.
Das ist eh das beste Emote hier, Keg 4D müsste das eigentlich heißen, eigentlich müsste
es Keg 4D heißen, das fände ich viel besser.
Nice, so Leute, habe ich irgendwas übersehen, warum sind 500 Leute auf einmal am Start, ist
die Anzeige falsch?
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen oder was?
Warte mal, what the fuck?
Warte mal, ich war ja gerade auf dem Klo und habe den Stream angemacht, ist in der Zwischenzeit
irgendwas passiert?
Ach, das Hulusi hat mich gehaust, jetzt habe ich mich überhaupt nicht gesehen, Alter, moin
Leute.
Huge, huge haus, Dankeschön, habe sie überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt.
Normalerweise steht das doch auch im Chat da, auf dem Luxus-Klo, korrekt, korrekt, auf
dem Luxus-Klo.
Wann hat er mich denn gehaust, habe ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt?
Dauert Dashboard vor einer Minute, na gut, ja Danny, danke für den Host, ich weiß nicht,
ob du gerade reinguckst, wahrscheinlich ist er direkt off, bettge, ich sag dir, du kommst
auch noch ins Boomer, Alter, du wirst irgendwann auch 20.15 schon müde.
Es fehlt nicht mehr viel, so, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen leiser.
Tja, und was habt ihr gemacht, ich vermute mal, ich vermute mal eine Runde in Warzone
geraget, weil das das einzige ist, was man in letzter Zeit in Warzone machen kann.
Ist eigentlich, ihr spielt ja öfters Warzone als ich, gehe ich mal von aus, also meine
Warzone-Spielzeit beschränkt sich auf ein paar Minuten und dann Rage Quit, aber wie
sieht das eigentlich aus, sind immer noch bestimmte Models unsichtbar, oder kann man
mittlerweile alles sehen wieder?
Ich frag mich eh, was ist mit Ravensoft eigentlich los, die kriegen irgendwie nix geschissen,
ich beobachte das ja nur am Rande, weiß gar nicht, ob ich überhaupt noch installiert hab,
ich beobachte das nur am Rande und bestimmte Hacker sind immer noch am Hacken, ja klar.
Ich hab letztens gelesen, dass sie wieder 50.000 Accounts gebannt haben in Warzone,
aber ich mein, was sind 50.000 Accounts über ein paar Wochen, wen juckts, ja, ist doch
fast nix.
Ja, ok, also Leute, dann legen wir mal los, 50k, ja, wenns reicht, wenns reicht, merci
if you chat.
Ja, also Dankeschön nochmal für den Host, Leute, heute machen wir ein bisschen Video-Vorbereitung,
kann man jetzt, ja, ja, unbedingt, schickt mir Stellenangebote, unbedingt, heute mach
ich ein bisschen Vorbereitung für, äh, mal wieder die schlechteste Jobseite aller Zeiten
aufmachen, äh, ich mach heute ein bisschen Vorbereitung für das nächste Stellenanzeigenvideo
und ich hab jetzt übrigens letztens ne Werbung bekommen, auf Twitter, von einem Laden, die
wir schon mal gezeigt haben, hier, guck mal, Pirate, ne, wie hießen die, Pirate, hier,
das da, der Infrastructure Engineer, es hat schon richtig Pains Champ, aiaiai, es hat
schon richtig Pains Champ, aber naja, oh, da muss jetzt, das muss jetzt, Moment, Moment,
Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, ich bin irgendwie dazu gekommen, ein Gespräch mit den Menschen
von Spot Rocker zu haben, ähm, hast du dich da beworben, also wenn ich frage, hast du
dich da beworben und wie, wie, wie war's so, ich glaube nämlich, ich glaube nämlich,
dass das, also die haben ja auch, die haben ja auch einen Kommentar unter, unter das Video
geschrieben bei mir und ich glaube, die haben einfach ein bisschen über das Ziel hinaus
geschossen mit dieser Stellenanzeige, ich glaube, die haben das einfach ein bisschen
schlecht durchdacht, wahrscheinlich sind die gar nicht so schlecht, und wie war's so,
und wie, wie war's so, oh, hab ich das Steamsack noch auf, weg, IT-Jobs für Fach- und Führungskraft,
also Führungskraft werde ich niemals, wäre nie im Leben, wünsch ich das machen freiwillig
und hast du gleich gesagt, ich bin, ich bin Abonnent von Max, ich hab da euch das Stellenanzeigen,
im Stellenanzeigen Video gesehen und er ist mal direkt, direkt Bann rausgeschmissen, wie
geht's dir denn heute, ähm, wie immer, wie immer nix, äh, weder sonderlich gut noch
sonderlich schlecht, so, so weird champ wie immer, aber wisst ihr Leute, was ihr machen
könnt, damit's mir, damit's mir viel, viel, dass ich, na, dass mein Gehirn noch, noch,
dass unser aller Gehirn noch größer wird, wenn ihr noch einen Prime-Sub offen habt,
könnt ihr mir einen Prime-Sub dalassen, weil ihr wisst ja, jeder Sub steigert den IQ des
kompletten Chats, irgendwann sind wir 11-Head und er platzt, was, vier Jahre, sehr ambitioniert
und am Ende hieß es das, dass ich, ich weiß gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, was die Läden
teilweise, ich muss kurz den Klima nach anschalten, ich weiß gar nicht, was die Läden so genau
wollen, wenn ich ehrlich bin, wenn ich da teilweise lese, so gefühlt 10 Jahre Kubernetes-Erfahrung,
wie lange gibt's den, kam noch gar nicht, der funktioniert immer, die Primers sind wieder
am Start, danke schön Leute, Ksugi, Prime-Sub, Massive-Subscription, gleich kommt das Scam-Train
noch hier, der Scam-Train, 94% Scam-Train ist wieder am Start, XD, Joel ist auch am Start,
94% Prime-Sub und das iB-Jewel 98, klingt ein bisschen wie ein Xbox Random Username,
vielleicht schätze ich das auch falsch ein, aber das klingt so wie das, was früher Xbox
Live generiert hat, vielleicht lege ich ja richtig, macht es Sinn mit Programmieren
als Hobby anzufangen, klar, warum nicht, naja, ob du jetzt, ob du jetzt, Moment mal, also,
da muss ich jetzt, ihr wisst, ich bin kein Game-Entwickler, aber da kann ich trotzdem
was zu sagen, also, mit Programmieren anzufangen, wenn es dir Spaß macht, immer Sinn und das
macht erstmal prinzipiell gar keinen Unterschied, ob du jetzt was für ein Mobile machen willst
oder ob du was für einen Desktop machen willst, Indie heißt ja nur, du entwickelst nicht
für irgendein Studio, außer halt vielleicht für dein eigenes, beziehungsweise du hast
keinen Publisher, also du kannst auch ein Indie-Mobile-Game machen, das ist auch kein
Problem, wow, was ist denn jetzt los, MAF LBR oder Mr.
Mr.
Flippere heißt das, Leute, übertreibt man nicht, MonkaS, Alter, porras, was ist denn
jetzt, so schnell komme ich überhaupt nicht hinterher, der Teapot, ja, Status, ATTP Status
Code, Alter, ok, ich muss jetzt, ich muss mich mal wieder beruhigen, also, Chat ist
wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil eh gedodged, alles klar, jetzt bin ich nicht mal Z-Geläude,
genau, so einfach geht, ich muss das einfach immer sagen, ich muss das einfach immer sagen,
ich bin so traurig, keine Primes auf Spam, ok, also, Dankeschön Mr.
Flippere, wahrscheinlich stimmt es überhaupt nicht, Dankeschön für die 5 Gegiften, Sab,
wir hatten Glück gehabt, der Liko, der hat es verdient auf jeden Fall, der ist schon
so lange und so oft dabei, äh, Diff, das kann ich nicht aussprechen, Diffesie, wie auch
immer, der Dinkelberg, Freddix und der Altis ist am Start, und jetzt kommt der Teapot,
zum Glück 418 statt 404, 10 Subs, Dankeschön für die Massive Subs Spam hier, wer hat denn
was abbekommen, RunUnder, der Wurzelzap, Artcore, Kenpachi90, Saunt, ok, Frexor, der Biowulf,
der Alpha TM und Petim, huge Subs Leute, da hätte ich jetzt gar nicht mit gerechnet,
Hermes, Dankeschön, auch nochmal hier, der Hook ist auch schon 13 Monate am Start, ich
kann ja gar nicht anfangen, 22 Uhr ist Bedgetime, wie soll ich das, aber richtig Hyper Subscriber,
Mr. Felber, ah Felber, verstehe, ok, da wäre ich jetzt anhand der Abkürzung nicht drauf
gekommen, jetzt weiß ich es, der Halbtrain, ja, jetzt hat er also alle abonniert hier,
Level 5 hat er schon eine Weile nicht mehr, wir machen am Ende nochmal Subraten, ich
war in den letzten 1-2 Wochen nicht mehr so richtig aktiv, ich habe ja nur noch sonntags
den Stream gemacht, in den letzten 2 Wochen, ich war ein bisschen beschäftigt, und da
sind jetzt das Subcount wieder hart gedroppt, Alter, das ist auf Twitch echt extrem, wenn
du konstant Streams, also konstant Stream heißt bei mir, keine Ahnung, 2-3 mal 2-3 Stunden
die Woche, also konstant, bei anderen ist konstant 7 Stunden am Tag, aber bei mir ist
das eher so 2-3 Stunden, 2-3 mal die Woche, aber wenn ich das durchhalte, dann bin ich
immer richtig begeistert, wie die Subzahlen nach oben gehen, dann bin ich 2 Wochen mal
wieder nicht so aktiv, BÄM, Subzahlen wieder im Keller, das ist einfach so, aber so ist
es halt, Twitch belohnt einen dafür, dass man aktiv ist, und das ist ja auch gut so.
Achso, einfach in den Chat mit nwupplos, falls ich was übersehen habe, wenn ihr schon was
geschickt habt, schickt es nochmal her, es war gerade so viel los im Chat, maxi69, danke
für den Sub, 500 einfach in den Chat, nwupplos davor, weil es thematisch passt, warum will
man aus guten 4Head Technikern, eigentlich du meinst 5Head, 4Head ist ja der Normalzustand,
also es gibt ja im Prinzip 3 Gehirnzustände, ja, 4Head ist der Normale, also zumindest
um es in Twitch Chat Emotes zu beschreiben, 4Head ist der Normale, weder besonders schlau
noch besonders dumm, dann gibt es die 3Head Variante, das ist dann schon eher so das Negative
und dann gibt es natürlich noch, um nicht zu vergessen, wo habe ich es denn, na, dann
gibt es die richtig exquisite Big Brain 5Head und falls, und falls ich viele Prime Subz bekomme,
dann irgendwann natürlich auch die 6Head Variante, aber das geht nur, wenn man hier im Chat immer
anwissen ist, wenn reingesubbt wird, sonst funktioniert das nicht, tja, das ist aber
jetzt tatsächlich, gute Frage, ich glaube der Trend ist eher umgedreht in den letzten
Jahren, also er sagt, warum will man eigentlich aus guten Technikern immer Manager machen,
die sich dann weiter von der Technik entfernen, das war ein Problem, oder das gibt es wahrscheinlich,
gibt es heute immer noch, ich will das jetzt nicht wegreden, aber ich glaube das Problem
ist rückläufig, weil man gemerkt hat, dass die Stärken, die man in den beiden, in diesen
beiden Themengebieten braucht, oftmals komplett aneinander vorbeigehen und man selten Leute
hat, die das eine gut können und zusätzlich das andere gut können.
Wichtig ist, dass vor allem ein guter Manager, sagen wir mal auch ein guter Teamleiter oder
auch ein guter Abteilungsleiter, dass der weiß, was seine Leute, also mit können meine ich
jetzt nicht, dass der weiß, welche Programmiersprache die können, sondern dass er sich sicher ist,
zumindest bei ein paar Leuten, denen er traut und weiß, was die können und was sie drauf
haben und sich dann auch auf die Entscheidung verlässt bzw. auf das, was ihm, nicht auf
die Entscheidung, das was ihm quasi erzählt wird, dann auch drauf verlässt und nicht
sagt ach nee, ich glaube euch nichts, ich habe da irgendwo mal was im Manager Magazin
gelesen oder in der letzten CT oder was auch immer, das ist glaube ich das, was gerade
auch viele neuen Manager oftmals lernen müssen, dass sie eben sich eingestehen müssen von
einer Materie keine Ahnung zu haben und dass es auch vollkommen okay ist und man wissen
muss oder sich die Leute rausgucken muss, auf die man hört bzw. denen man halt Glauben
schenkt.
Aber das ist glaube ich ein Problem, das geht weg mit der Zeit, zumindest bei uns ist es
mittlerweile so, ich muss ja noch was zu sagen, also eines der Probleme, warum das überhaupt
gemacht wurde, war ja folgendes, dass es keine Möglichkeiten gab, wie nennen wir es mal,
Karriere zu machen, aufzusteigen, voranzukommen wie auch immer, also Stonks, Karriere Stonks
zu machen, wenn man nicht ins Management gegangen ist, das war ja gerade, ihr wisst ja, ich
arbeite in Frankfurt bei einer Bank, da ist das natürlich besonders oldschool, ich muss
noch ein bisschen leiser machen, da ist das natürlich besonders oldschool und du hattest
keine Möglichkeiten früher als Techniker dich weiterzuentwickeln, du hast deinen Technikerkram
gemacht und wenn du Glück hattest, warst du vielleicht mal irgendwie Hauptansprechpartner
für ein gewisses Themengebiet oder sonst was und das war's.
Patrick, wir haben noch gar nicht angefangen, ich wurde gehostet und habe ganz viele Prime
Maps gekriegt und das hat mich ein bisschen aus der Bahn geworfen, ich habe jetzt noch
gar nicht angefangen, zumal er eh in eineinhalb Stunden ist wieder Bettgetimed, so und dementsprechend
haben sich viele Techniker dazu entschlossen, sie müssen, um weiterzukommen, irgendeine
Managergeschichte machen, sei es Projektleiter oder sei es sich als Teamleiter zu versuchen
oder sonst was, was natürlich für alle Seiten doof war, kann man als Chat den Viewer irgendwie
abdocken, ja genau so wie ich es hier gemacht habe, das hat übrigens unten glaube ich auch
ein Knopf dafür zum Abdocken, Patrick die Leute, Patrick sagt Leute die um 10 ins Bett
gehen sind etwas lost, wart mal ab, ich weiß du kommst auch langsam in die Jahre, ja wart
mal ab, du hast letztens ja schon erzählt, du merkst schon das beim Mittagessen müde
wirst, das ist der Anfang vom Ende, ich sag's euch, wenn ihr merkt, dass ihr nach dem Mittagessen
am liebsten Mittagsschlaf machen wollt, dann wisst ihr ja langsam ist vorbei, also genau
so sieht's aus mit Techniker, Techniker und Managern und das konnten die Leute halt dementsprechend
nicht und es ist natürlich auch das Problem gewesen, dass der Chef vom Chef das auch nicht
gerne gehabt hat, wenn dann jemanden fähiger Techniker quasi weg war, das Problem erledigt
sich aber glaube ich gerade, weil man erkannt hat, dass man Techniker auch Karrieremöglichkeiten
bieten muss, die was anderes als Management sind, ja siehst du, Handy Primus, Heisenberg
1979, danke schön für den Primesup, oi, richtig, Seven Head haben wir nicht, Eleven
Head, Eleven Head haben wir glaube ich, haben wir Eleven Head, nee haben wir auch nicht,
fehlt noch, ist das doch nice, das weiß ich nicht mehr, welches Gameplay das war, aber
ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, dass ich damals recht viele Videos dazu gemacht habe,
wobei ich immer noch recht viele Videos zu mache, also ich werde nächste Woche ein Video
machen, Top Tipps für Fachinformatiker, Azubis, da arbeite ich schon eine Weile dran, so als
Ideen zu sammeln und jetzt ist das fertig und es passt aktuell auch ziemlich gut, gerade
laufen Abschlussprüfungen und dann fangen die neuen Leute ja auch bald an, wer nutzt
eigentlich Plant, keiner, das ist einfach standardmäßig mal mitinstalliert, ich kenne
niemand, der das verwendet, Schnüppel, dankeschön für den Snap, ja nicht zwangsläufig, finde
ich gar nicht, der muss wissen, auf wen er hört oder wen er fragen kann, der muss sich
nicht zwangsläufig mit Technik auskennen, alter Leko 50 Milliarden Bits hier, jetzt spammt
er, da sind Leute, die einfach nicht drauf hören können, was ihnen die Leute die Ahnung
haben sagen, da sind aber schlechte Manager, das kenne ich, das ist echt lustig das Video,
das kann man später mal gucken, das ist wirklich gut, so das ist aber erstaunlich nah an der
Realität dran, so ich muss jetzt mal den Chat jetzt hier aufholen, 16 Bit, Super Nintendo
persönlich am Start, siehst du, da weißt du, langsam ist vorbei und im Oktober geht's,
das würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, warum machst du nach deiner Ausbildung direkt ein
Film, also das interessiert mich immer, wenn die Leute sich dafür entscheiden, was der
Hintergrund ist, wenn du es verraten willst, kannst du ja mal in den Chat schreiben, würde
mich interessieren, ja und einer der Tipps ist natürlich, meinen Hetzner 20 Euro Startgutschein
einzulösen, das ist natürlich klar, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner in den Chat, ich habe, oh nein, ich
habe den neuen Ref Link noch gar nicht drinne, jetzt habe ich hier, jetzt wird das noch nicht
mal gezählt, ich habe den neuen Ref Link noch gar nicht drinne, vor 3 Wochen Prüfung
gehabt, ja dann kannst du dir einen Senf dazu abgeben, ob es dir was gebracht hätte, aber
ich glaube für alle, die jetzt neu anfangen, wann geht denn das los Leute, wann fangen
denn neue Azubis an, das ist doch jetzt August, September, Oktober, so die nächsten 3 Monate
sind das doch jetzt oder, also, ja genau es kommt nämlich immer ein bisschen drauf an
auf die Firma und was, das Knowhow nach der Ausbildung war bad, na gut, das liegt aber
auch ein bisschen mit an dir, ne, C-Sharp und Ruby, Ruby, heute war es bei uns, ok, will
nach der Ausbildung noch mal die Freiheit im Studium haben, verschiedene Themen, oh ja,
verstehe, du wirst vor allem erstmal viel Mathe machen müssen, was machst du eigentlich,
wenn dein Ausbildungsbetrieb insolvent geht, neue Stelle suchen, ich weiß gar nicht, darf
man seine Abschlussprüfung machen, wenn der Betrieb insolvent anmeldet, das geht bestimmt,
wenn man schon irgendwie, keine Ahnung, angenommen du hast 2 Jahre, 2,5 Jahre schon hinter dir,
dann darfst du bestimmt die Prüfung machen, wer von euch ist über 30, ich tippe mal drauf,
so knapp die Hälfte, ne, nicht so viel, 30% sind über 30, wollen wir mal ne Umfrage
machen, wer über 30 ist, wollen wir mal ne Umfrage, Leute, wollen wir mal ne Umfrage,
toll, Umfrage, ich mach mal, ich mach mal, wie alt seid ihr, wir machen, wir machen,
wir machen, welche Abstufung machen wir denn, wir machen unter 20, 20-30, 30-40 und 40 plus,
oder, ja, das passt schon, zusätzliche Abstimmung zulassen, nein Twitch, das machen wir nicht,
Umfrage, Beginn, Bäm, zeig mal, bin ich mal gespannt, muss auch abstimmen, bin ich eingeloggt,
bin ich eingeloggt, ja, das dachte ich mir, dass die meisten gar nicht so alt sind, also
guck mal, der überwiegende Teil ist unter 30, was ist denn mal, ich hab gar nicht gedacht,
wir haben, wir haben also, sagen wir mal, so 15% über 30 und 85% unter 30, nice, ich bin
übrigens, ich muss, ich muss übrigens tatsächlich öfters nachdenken, weil ich hab demnächst
Geburtstag und werd 37 und ich bin schon seit ein paar Jahren verwirrt, ob es jetzt 36,
37, 38, 35 oder sonst was, ich muss da jedes Mal nachgucken, ok, also, eindeutig hat gewonnen
20-30, wisst ihr mal, und wisst ihr was das coole daran ist, dass saumäßig viele Leute
von YouTube am Start sind, die mich angefangen haben teilweise mit 12, 13 zu gucken, Leute,
wer ist von YouTube dabei, ich mein's jetzt übrigens nicht negativ, ich mein's jetzt
nicht negativ, wer ist, wer ist von YouTube dabei, ab dem Alter, wo er noch ein kleiner
Scheißer war, nichts gegen kleine Scheißer, ok, ganz schön viele, null, wobei ich ja immer
wieder überrascht bin, wie viele Leute auf Twitch hier am Start sind, die es nur über
Twitch kennen, die gar nicht über YouTube gekommen sind, gut, ich mein, ich bin ja auch,
wann war mein erster Stream, vor 3 Jahren oder so, ist auch schon ein bisschen her, Schneestelze
von YouTube, das weiß ich, wusste ich nicht, das weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt, kann
schon sein, dann macht die IHK wenigstens einmal was Sinnvolles, siehste, und das übrigens,
MrFelber, Felber, ah, das hab ich schon wieder vergessen, egal, das hab ich von vielen Leuten
schon gehört, die gesagt haben, und die ja auch öfters hier im Chat sind, also schon
im Chat gewesen sind und haben gesagt, hey, ohne das Video, was ich damals gesehen hätte,
von dir auf YouTube hätt ich das gar nicht gemacht, das finde ich natürlich immer äußerst,
äußerst nice, ne, äh, Moment, das hab ich, hab ich verklickt, wo hab ich's denn, hier,
natürlich, oh, also die IHK ist halt die Frage, was die überhaupt so macht, ich hoffe, das
machen sie wirklich, Profilbild auf Xing geändert, also, mein, ich hab immer noch das beste Profilbild
auf Xing, nicht auf Xing, auf LinkedIn, Peter, wo ist er, da, also, gegen, gegen, gegen mein
Xing, äh, LinkedIn, Profilbild, die, guck mal, die anderen sind alle so seriös, die
sind, guckt euch das an, die sind alle so seriös hier auf LinkedIn, ja, das Profil existiert
immer noch, die haben das nicht gelöscht, die haben das nicht gelöscht, oh, da gibt's
ein Fake, da gibt's ein Faker, ein Fake Peter Agile, was ist denn hier los, in Stuttgart,
in der Detätsdiebstahl, Kirk Wade, was ist da los, Sus, auf GitHub sind die Anime-Bilder
immer Big Brain Open Source Contributor, das stimmt, ja, alles, Battlefield, ja, ich hoffe,
mit 2042 geht's mir da, gibt's ja ein bisschen Battlefield Zeug, ja, so geht's mir auch,
man muss sich vorstellen, in der letzten Zeit ist wirklich verdammt viel passiert, wo ich
klein war, gab es noch nicht mal normale Handys, wir reden hier nicht von Smartphones, von
stinknormalen Handys, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, das waren Zeiten, wo auf
einem Konzert die Leute sich das Konzert angeguckt haben oder im besten Fall noch mal mit einem
Feuerzeug gewedelt haben, ohne das Handy am Start zu haben, wieso ist im Stream ein anderer
Chat, weil ich zu langsam bin, hinterher zu kommen, ja, ein bisschen Boomer Time muss
da immer sein, wenn du regelmäßig streams, würde ich dich abonnieren, guck doch mal
bei mir in die Video-History, regelmäßig ist Definitionsfrage, nein, ich streame nicht
regelmäßig, regelmäßig heißt ja jeden eins bis zweiten Tag, das mache ich nicht,
du bist nicht der einzige, der mein Profil gemeldet hat, also überhaupt kein Problem,
ich glaube, LinkedIn hat das Profil irgendwie als Influencer-Account markiert oder sowas,
weil die letzten meiner Fake-Profile wurden instant gelöscht und das Profil, was ich in
einem Video gezeigt habe, haben sie quasi nie angefasst, ich glaube, die haben intern
irgendwie sowas, die solche Profile markieren, ey Max und Jett, was würdet ihr empfehlen,
um den Bereich zu wechseln ERP zu Web, wir gucken, ob es bei euch Leute in der Richtung
brauchen oder aber, was ich bei uns auf der Arbeit immer ganz gut finde oder was zumindest
bei uns ganz gut funktioniert, man kann oftmals bei uns auch themenübergreifende Sachen machen,
ohne jetzt wirklich hauptberuflich da in einem anderen Team zu sein, ich mogel mich auch öfters
mal bei Dingern rein, wo es darum geht, Sachen zu programmieren oder irgendwas zu testen
oder sonst wie, einfach weil mir das Spaß macht und ich nicht manches anderen Sachen
nicht so viel Bock hab, dann mach ich lieber das, ja und das ist tatsächlich in dem Fall
nicht schlecht, wenn du was anderes machen willst, red mit deinem Chef und sag ihm das,
das heißt ja nicht, dass du das Team scheißt, wenn du wechseln willst, weil du das Team
scheißt, dann ist das vielleicht was anderes, aber wenn du interessensmäßig wechseln willst,
ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt an Chef zu fragen, letztendlich ist das ja die Aufgabe
von deinem Chef, sowas zu koordinieren und zu planen, ein Chef kriegt ja nicht einfach
nur an der Stelle Geld um Chef zu sein, sondern dann muss ich auch was dafür machen, also
das erste, was ich je hatte, an so moderner Elektronik, nennen wir es mal so, war ein
Gameboy, 1900, frag mir nicht, 90 oder so oder 91, weiß gar nicht, wann ist denn der Gameboy
in Europa rausgekommen, Gameboy Release, ja hier, ja dann hatte ich's 1991 oder so, hat
mir damals mein Vater gekauft, heute weiß ich ja, ich hab's euch ja schon erzählt,
heute weiß ich auch von welchem Geld, mein Vater war ja der Scammer in Person, der hat
schon gescampt die Leute lange bevor es Internet gab, richtig Scammer hast du ja, ich muss
es ja nicht jedes Mal erzählen, ich hab's ja schon oft genug erzählt, ja ist halt heute
so, ne, so jetzt bin ich mit dem Chat bald mal durch, gibt's da einen Clip zu, ah bestimmt,
ich glaube sogar im letzten oder vorletzten Wort hab ich's nochmal erzählt, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, da lass ich mich jetzt nicht debaten, da lass ich mich jetzt nicht
rein debaten, auf diese Frage, das sag ich heute nichts zu, so was ich mir mit euch angucken
wollte, ich weiß aber nicht ob wir das heute machen, weil eigentlich ist das Thema des
heutigen Streams und wir haben schon 2047 eigentlich, ich wollte mir ein paar Stellenanzeigen
raussuchen, die ich fürs nächste Video verwenden kann und mir hat auch ja schon jemand eine
neue Stellenanzeige geschickt, war das das hier, die mir jemand im Chat gerade geschickt
hat, aber das wollte ich mir trotzdem mit euch mal schnell angucken, Meinung zu Cobalt,
beste Programmiersprache aller Zeiten, dicht gefolgt von Fortran, dann ABAP, wobei, das
sind jetzt drei mehr oder weniger komplett zusammenhanglose Dinge, aber ok, das wollte
ich mir mit euch kurz mal angucken, denn es hat JetBrains, also die Typen, die Kotlin
und IDE's und so basteln, die haben eine Umfrage gemacht, was beliebte Programmiersprachen
sind und Betriebssysteme, wo entwickelt wird und eine Sache, das können wir uns einen
anderen mal dann in Ruhe angucken, aber eine Sache, die ich persönlich äußerst interessant
fand, ist das hier, Betriebssystemauswahl, guckt mal, auf welchem Betriebssystem entwickelt
ihr, also die Frage ist nicht exakt für welches Betriebssystem entwickelt ihr, sondern auf
welchem Betriebssystem entwickelt ihr und 61% Windows, 47% Linux, andere wahrscheinlich
Solaris oder irgendein Kack, Oldschool Zeug, WSL zählt als Windows, ja, WSL kommt hier
unten drunter die Frage, wer Windows gesagt hat, hat die extra Frage zu WSL bekommen,
WSL zählt zu Windows, das kann durchaus sein, dass es Multiple Choice ist, ich vermute sogar
mal, dass es Multiple Choice ist, es muss ja Multiple Choice sein, sonst könnte man
hier nicht auf irgendwie 150% oder sowas kommen, aber trotzdem, daran sieht man, dass gerade
was technisch interessiert und als, wie soll ich sagen, Bastelbetriebssystem ist Linux
einfach ungeschlagen.
Das hier sind die ganzen Webdesigner, die Mac-Leute kann man mal rausrechnen, ja, das
sind irgendwelche, möchte gern Web, HTML-Programmierer, die brauchen wir nicht, die müssen wir nicht
beachten, wichtig, wichtig ist das hier, bei uns ist das auch so, bei uns sind die einzigen,
die mit Mac arbeiten, hauptsächlich die iOS-Leute, HTML-Programmierer, klar, guck hier, HTML-Programmierer,
siehst du doch, eindeutig HTML-Programmierer, glaube, das müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr weiter
debattieren, wenn sogar eines der größten Hersteller von Developer Tools, HTML und CSS
als Programming-Language auffasst und extra noch einen Disclaimer reinmacht, dann können
wir das durchaus bei solchen Umfragen dazu nehmen, TempleOS, stimmt, stimmt, andere ist
bestimmt TempleOS, ja, das wird es sein, ja, das bei Rust immer so, das ist bei Rust lustigerweise
immer so, die Leute sagen, wow Rust, Rust ist so cool und dann fangen sie an Rust zu
programmieren und dann habe ich gedacht, Scheiße, Rust ist ja anstrengend als Fuck, ah, vielleicht
lasse ich das doch, wie viele von den 47% benutzen es in der VM jetzt, das weiß man
nicht, ich vermute allerdings mal ein nicht unerheblicher Anteil, weil ich glaube, viele
werden das so machen wie ich, ich mache das gerade mal an, das sind die Leute immer, wie,
habe ich das gestoppt beim starten, das, die immer begeistert, ich benutze Windows mit
der Linux VM auf dem zweiten Desktop, ich glaube, das machen tatsächlich nicht, nicht
unerheblicher Teil, also Rust ist wirklich, du brauchst, wie der Patrick sagt, Next Level
Brain, um Rust zu programmieren, aber die Umfrage finde ich trotzdem interessant, also
das ist das, was ich euch zeigen wollte, guckt mal, wie viele Leute, zumindest auch auf dem
zweiten, also Alternativ dazu, noch Linux verwenden, ich mache es ja auch so, zum Beispiel
Windows Zeug mache ich halt unter Windows und alles andere mache ich unter Linux, wie
gesagt, ich programmiere sogar mittlerweile.NET zum größten Teil nur noch unter Linux,
außer es ist Windows Anwendung, ist es nicht eine, Moment, ist es nicht, warte mal, ich
bin nicht in der Lage zu lesen, ist es nicht einfacher, was, ist nicht eine Windows, ach
so, okay, ist nicht eine Windows, nein, nein, nein, nein, es ist viel einfacher, es ist
viel einfacher, Linux unter Windows laufen zu lassen, als Windows unter Linux, die einzige
Ausnahme, und das macht keiner, weil es andere Nachteile hat, ist sowas mit Grafikkarten
Pass-Through, dass du quasi, dass du Linux als Host hast und dann noch die Grafikkarte,
die extra Grafikkarte, die du durchreichst an deine VM, plus noch am besten eine zweite
Maus, die du durchreichst und eine zweite Tastatur, die du durchreichst, und du hast
quasi zwei Rechner in einem, das mag funktionieren oder, ja, oder du hast ein KVM, was du umschaltest,
wie auch immer, wenn man dieses Setup haben will, ist es wahrscheinlich effizienter oder
die einzige Möglichkeit, aber wenn man das einfach nur benutzen will, wenn du einfach
nur sagst, hey, ich brauche Windows zum Spielen und halt Sachen, die es so nur unter Windows
gibt, dann Windows als Host und Linux in der VM ist die viel, viel einfache Variante,
weil, Alter, weil Linux in der VM ziemlich, ziemlich gut läuft mit den Standard VM-Wertreibern,
wohingegen Windows in der VM unter Linux nicht so richtig gut läuft.
Hier wechselst du so schnell, ich habe das auf dem zweiten Desktop hier, guck, erster
Desktop das, zweiter Desktop das, und du kannst dann, wenn du drückst, Windows Control und
kannst die Desktops durchswitchen, by the way, weil der Chat sich immer freut, ich zeige
euch heute auch nochmal meinen Desktop, ich weiß, der Chat mag meinen Desktop.
Ja, also, so mache ich das, man muss einfach auch ein bisschen durcheinander überblicken.
Also, ich finde es viel besser, Linux unter Windows als umgedreht, nee, die Umfrage da
drunter ist WSL, das ist nicht Linux unter Windows, also das ist nicht, so wie ich es
habe, VM-Wert mit Linux, das ist nur WSL.
Kann man eigentlich dann Mean-Pap-Vers-Mean-Board irgendwie bekommen, nee, das habe ich, das
habe ich über die letzten Streaming-Jahre gesammelt, das sind natürlich auch bei weitem
nicht komplett, aber ich habe nur die oft benutzten hier drinnen, weil, ansonsten komme
ich ja nicht mehr klar, wenn ich hier noch dreimal so viel drin hätte, würde ich gar
nicht durchpicken.
Also, manche Sachen sind echt ein bisschen underused, muss ich sagen, manche Sachen
sind echt ein bisschen underused, also ich glaube, so eines meiner Lieblingssachen ist
natürlich der da, ja, der da, und selbstverständlich, wo ist er, der da, die habe ich beide gern,
ja.
Stadia habe ich immer nur, damit ich sagen kann, Stadia, oder Stadia, oder Stadia, ja,
oder Stadia, oder Stadia, Moment, wo habe ich, oder Stadia, Stadia, ja, Keg Windows
ist auch gut, KegWade brauchen wir auch, Subscriber Sounds, natürlich, natürlich auch, ja, so,
und der ist ein bisschen underused in letzter Zeit, der ist echt ein bisschen underused
hier, aber es war fast schon Monka Tost, vielleicht war der Clip schon zu lang, wie hast du den
Hyper-Subscriber Sound gemacht, das ist eine, die Musik ist zu laut, das ist eine koreanische
Text-to-Speech, äh, ne, eine japanische, das ist eine japanische Text-to-Speak-Engine,
wo man einstellen kann, wie glücklich die Sprecherin ist, und wir haben einfach gesagt,
Sprecherin, glücklichste Sprecherin von allen, und da kommt Hyper-Subscriber raus, oder auch
um die Leute zu trollen, den mache ich in letzter Zeit aber weniger, kann man den Link haben
für ein Schulprojekt, ne, kannst du nicht, es gibt keinen Link dazu, das habe ich programmiert
und habe nur eine uralt Version auf GitHub, ja, und normalerweise bediene ich das ja von
der zweiten, Moment mal, das ist wieder geblendet, naja, viel besser, gut, gucken wir uns das
nächste Mal in Ruhe an, nicht jetzt, ich speichere mir das mal, also das hat jemand geschickt,
wenn ihr noch lustige Stellen anzeigen habt, Leute, haut's mir in den Chat, weil ich brauch
welche für das nächste Video, muss man vor allem eine Pro-Version haben, um mehrere VMs
in Tabs zu öffnen, weiß ich nicht, gute Frage, das ist proprietäre Software, ja nicht ganz,
es gibt auf GitHub, es gibt auf GitHub so eine schnell zusammengehackte Version von 2018,
mit den besten Comment-Messages aller Zeiten, alles klar, okay, ich habe mir teilweise Mühe
gegeben mit den, guck mal, das Series Max ist auch am Start, und der Auskenn-Fuchs persönlich
hat Contributed damals, welches Linux das ist, das ist Arch, by the way, Majaro mit
i3 als Window-Manager, so, also jetzt habe ich glaube ich den Chat komplett durch, das
ist ein
Oh, MonkaS, Musik, Alter!
Richtig nice, 500 Viewer gucken mir hinzu beim Nichts machen, ja das ist äußerst nice.
Eigentlich wollte ich mir jetzt Stellenanzeige angucken.
Okay, durchrollen, schnell.
Ja, Chain-Law ist gut.
So, also, fangen wir mal an, das hat mir gerade jemand geschickt, gucken wir uns das doch
mal an.
Also, Stellenanzeige, für, was 2021, 10, nee, 2021, 100, was sagt uns das, 2021, 100?
Nein, er hat es nicht gelesen, was habe ich nicht gelesen?
100% Stelle, 100% Anzeige, benutzt doch Alt-Shift-D, Alt-Shift-D, oh, komm mal hier, hier lernt
man wieder was, Educational Stream, Leute, die Subs haben sich schon wieder richtig gelohnt,
IQ ist Extended geworden, richtig Extended IQ, Alter, was ist denn heute los?
So, da haben wir noch was, ein Software-Engineer-Photoshop, oh, das ist bestimmt richtig Big-Brain-Time,
okay, also, zeig mal her, was wird denn, Bildung, Rechenzentrum, fürs Rechenzentrum, alles
klar, das ist unglaublich schlecht formatiert, das Ding, also Bildung, Kultur, Diversität,
Digitalisierung, aha, ist das das Motto der Universität Heidelberg?
Wahrscheinlich, im Rechenzentrum ist zum nächsten möglichen Zeitpunkt eine Stelle als IT-Netzwerkspezialistin,
IT-Netzwerkspezialist, männlich-weiß-deutsch, verfügbar, TVLE, das ist Tarif, ne, ne, das
ist, das ist, ähm, diese Gehaltstabelle, TV, was ist denn das, TVLE13, das da, seh ich
mal, ja gut, je nachdem, welche, welche, TV, was, TVL, TV, ach ne, nicht Heidelberg, Hildesheim,
komm ich auf Heidelberg, ja die gibt's auch, so, ähm, ich hab bis heute noch nicht verstanden,
wie der Kram funktioniert, also du wirst wahrscheinlich nicht damit einsteigen, sondern wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen größer, wenn du, wenn du mehr kannst, also gehen wir mal davon aus, man
bekommt, gehen wir mal davon aus, du bekommst das hier, ähm, und das dann wahrscheinlich
mal zwölf, das ist dann, das ist dann schon durchaus in Ordnung, E13 ist Einstieg mit
Einzieher, aber die können ja nicht sagen, wenn jemand sich bewirbt, der irgendwie, keine
Ahnung, 15 Jahre Erfahrung hat und richtig big brain ist, du kannst ja nicht sagen, steigst
automatisch mit Eins ein, ja, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, die haben da auch durchaus
die Möglichkeit, mein Auge zuzudrücken, also wenn die, wenn die den guten Kandidat haben
und der sagt, über 48.000 Euro im Jahr arbeite ich nicht, dann, dann müssen die ja sagen,
ja, dann kriegste mehr, wenn die ihn haben wollen, was anderes bleibt ihnen da nicht
übrig.
Notori gesagt hat mit Stufe 7 angefangen, ja Stufe 7 ist eindeutig die hier, ja, die,
dies ist die beste Stufe, also selbst wenn die Stufe die Jahre der Berufserfahrung ist,
ist das alles dehnbar, wie gesagt, ich hab auch nach der Ausbildung, wo ich, ich war
danach noch ein paar Jahre beim Provider und bin dann gewechselt, hab ich auch mehr Berufsjahre
angerechnet bekommen, als ich eigentlich hatte, also, dass ich glaube, das ist, ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ich kenn mich da so, Tarifvertrag öffentlichen Dienst nicht so wirklich aus,
ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass man hat da gewissen, gewissen Spielraum, es wäre
ja auch bescheuert, ja, es wäre ja auch bescheuert zu sagen, hey, man hat den perfekten Kandidaten
gefunden, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre Netzwerkerfahrung und jetzt sagt man, ne, ne, du musst, du musst
für, du musst für 48.000 Euro im Jahr anfangen, warum ist bei mir das, das im Chat so klein,
ich glaub das ist manchmal ein bisschen broken, aber ich, ich machs für dich nochmal groß,
also jetzt lass mal, lass mal lesen, was schreiben sie ansonsten auch so, wie, da gibt's keinen
Spielraum, also wenn es da wirklich keinen Spielraum gibt, dann bekommen die schlichten
ergreiften keine guten Leute, deswegen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es da, wenn
du kannst ja nicht zu einem sagen, ne, 20 Jahre Erfahrung hat sich richtig gut dafür
eignen, sie müssen jetzt für, müssen für die Hälfte ihres bisherigen Jahresgehalts
arbeiten und wenn, dann musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn du keinen bekommst, ich kann's
mir nicht vorstellen, aber gut, wenn ihr das sagt, wir wissen, wir wissen ja, Chat ist
prinzipiell immer, immer richtig, liegt immer richtig, hatten wir es letztens, ich glaub
im letzten Stream oder so, da war der Chat ja auch wieder ganz besonders richtig und am
Ende hat sich rausgestellt, es gibt überhaupt nicht, was der Chat gesagt hat, aber das kann
ja eigentlich gar nicht sein, also, was suchen sie, Netzwerkspezialist, unbefristet zu besetzen,
bei vorliegen der Beamten, Moment, der was, der Beamten rechtlichen Voraussetzungen in
entsprechenden Aufgaben wird die Lenkfresse, was, okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was ist,
aber es klingt bei mir eh nicht vor, okay, also die Stellenanzeige ist wirklich massiv
schlecht formatiert, also, Weiterentwicklung, Administration des Hochschulnetzwerks, okay,
das klingt relativ normal, Erstellen und Fortentwicklung eines Betriebskonzepts, okay, ja, weiß mir
nicht genau, was sie wollen, aber ja, Strategische Weiterentwicklung zur Sicherstellung der Zukunft,
boah, Alter, das ist aber auch ne ziemlich vage, vage Aussage, oder, Strategische Weiterentwicklung
zur Sicherung der Zukunftsfähigkeit, ich mein, dass ich mir ein bisschen Gedanken
drüber machen muss, über das, was ich so betreibe, ob ich das in 5 Jahren noch so betreiben kann,
ist okay, aber das ist so wirklich sehr, und das vor allem als ersten und zweiten Punkt
reinzuschreiben, wo man normalerweise sagt, zu ersten zwei Punkte, also, zumindest lese
ich das immer so, dass die Wichtigkeit von oben nach unten geht, und das ist zwei schon
ziemlich vage Punkte, ja, Konzeptionierung und Durchführung von Projekten, okay, das
hat jetzt eigentlich mit Netzwerkspezialist wenig zu tun, es sei denn, es sei denn, die
meinen, Konzeptionierung und Durchführung von Netzwerkerweiterung und sowas, dann sollen
sie das aber auch schreiben, weil von Projekten kann ja alles, kann ja alles sein, Konfiguration,
Betrieb und Wartung des Hochschulnetzes an allen Standorten der Universität, oder bist
du, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Standorte die haben, aber da bist du ziemlich Turnschuhadmin
mäßig unterwegs. Überwachung des Hochschulnetzwerk-Monitoring,
gut, das gehört auf jeden Fall dazu, wenn du Netzwerkspezialist bist, musst du auch
deine Switche und Router, oder ob es mal cool zu sagen, Router, musst du natürlich wissen,
wenn da was kaputt ist, das ergibt Sinn, Analyse und Beseitigung von Störungen, natürlich,
dafür bist du da, kontinuierliche Dokumentation des Hochschulnetzwerkes, das ist zum Beispiel
ein überflüssiger Punkt, wenn das Netzwerk gut aufgebaut ist, dann dokumentiert sich
das wie gute Software selbst, also da ist es komplett overrated, braucht man nicht.
Ok, Beratung von Mitgliedern und Angehörigen der Universitäts-Second-Level-Support, ok,
das heißt im Endeffekt, die rufen dich irgendwo an, die sagen dort, ich hab keine Ahnung,
ich frag mal unseren Netzwerk-Mensch, dann rufen die dich an und du sagst, ja der Typ
hat seinen Netzwerkstecker nicht reingesteckt oder so, oder guckst mal nach, ja, das ist
doch, also ich muss sagen, das klingt vollkommen normal, das da oben eher sehr vage, müssen
wir mal genauer wissen, was die da eigentlich sich darunter vorstellen, so, Mitwirkung bei
der Ausbildung der Fachinformatikerinnen in Theorie und Praxis des Netzwerkbetriebs,
klar, kann man machen, viele wollen das ja nicht, das ist ja grad der Witz, ich kann
mich noch dran erinnern, da wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe, nachdem ich fertig war, wollten
die mir damals verbieten, das ist kein Witz, die wollten mir damals verbieten mich um Azubis
zu kümmern, die haben gesagt so nach dem Motto, wir bezahlen dich nicht fürs Ausbilden von
Azubis, der Felix zum Beispiel, wo ich ein Gamescom Video damals gemacht habe, der war
ja auch noch Azubi, der war ein Jahr nach mir, darfst du nicht, nicht ein Jahr, zwei,
drei Jahre sogar, wollen sie nicht, was natürlich auch das ganze Sache komplett widerspricht,
weil es die eigenen Azubis sind, richtig hängen geblieben, die wollten nicht, durften nicht,
habe ich trotzdem gemacht, habe ich trotzdem gemacht und mache ich bis heute auch immer
noch gerne mich um Azubis kümmern, sogar um den Shitmaster, also ich glaube der kann
sich nicht beschweren, weiß nicht ob er guckt, nee ich glaube nicht, dass er zuguckt, aber
mit dem wollte ich demnächst noch ein Video machen, auch Herr Endpunkt glaube ich kann
sich da echt nicht beschweren, ich habe mich echt gut um die Azubis gekümmert, die bei
mir waren, auch wenn er einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch hatte, aber da konnte ich nichts für, egal,
Mitarbeit im rechten Zentrums internen Projekten, ok das ergibt Sinn, Vertretung anderer Systemadministrator
innen, ok die sind sich mit dem Gender nicht so ganz einig, wie sie es jetzt machen wollen,
wollen sie es so machen, wollen sie es so machen oder wollen sie es so machen, ist nicht
ganz klar, zum Beispiel WLAN Support, wie darf man sich WLAN Support vorstellen, man
läuft mit einer Antenne durchs Gerät, durchs Gebäude oder wie, was ist denn WLAN Support,
was genau darf man sich mit WLAN Support vorstellen, weiss nicht, VoIP, IGIT, hör mir auf, Videokonferenzsysteme,
Vertretung des Rechts, also das klingt wie nach einem Turnschuhadmin, der ein bisschen
Minimal Management Zeug mitmachen soll, an sich klingt das in Ordnung, wobei ich sagen
muss, ich glaube, dass das ein ziemlich undankbarer Job ist, ach die Leute haben ihr Passwort
vergessen und sowas, das ist WLAN Support, ah verstehe, aber ich dachte mal nicht Second
Level, das sollte doch jemand vorher machen, also ich glaube, es ist ok, aber es ist denke
ich ein relativ undankbarer Job, die werden dich nicht ordentlich bezahlen wollen, und
du bist im Endeffekt der Depp für alles, da wird es am Endeffekt drauf rauslaufen, also
ich glaube nicht, dass man da wirklich glücklich wird mit, ok Voraussetzung, Moment, was?
Was? Was ist der Sinn? Ok, vergleichbare Qualifikation steht ja auch noch drin, aber
Master, Master der Informatik, Elektrotechnik oder Nachrichtentechnik oder Informatik, das
ist doch hängen geblieben, was fuck, dazu sind glaube ich sogar Leute mit Master Abschluss
sogar weniger geeignet als Leute, die mal Physik gelernt haben und das schon 5 Jahre
machen, weil du musst einfach Praxiserfahrung haben hierfür, ob du jetzt theoretisch die
Algorithmuslaufzeit bestimmen kannst, ist da zweitrangig, naja, mehrere Einschläge Berufserfahrung
bezogen auf das Aufgabengebiet, also ich glaube die wenigsten Master in Informatik haben,
egal, egal, ja und dann auch noch Master in Elektrotechnik, weil das damit ja auch so
viel zu tun hat, also im Prinzip labern die aber auch plus rum, das hier ist das Entscheidende,
du musst wissen, was du machst, ich glaube das ist einfach so geschrieben, weil die wieder
irgendeine komische gesetzliche Anforderung oder irgendeine Richtlinie haben, dass das
so geschrieben sein muss, in Wirklichkeit nehmen die auch einer, den einen der Netzwerkeratmen
war irgendwo 5 Jahre oder 10 Jahre oder was auch immer und einfach Ahnung hat.
Master heißt du sollst jung sein aufs Alter bezogen, nein, Master heißt du hast ein Informatikstudium
gemacht mit Masterabschluss, so, aber es geht auch weiter, das Weiteren erwarten wir, sehr
gute Kenntnis und Erfahrung im Betrieb in der Administration von komplexen Netzwerken,
gut, das würde ich für einen Netzwerkspezialist erwarten, dass der Ahnung von Netzwerk hat,
LAN, WLAN und deren Switches, Router, Firewalls, Intrusion Detection Systems, fundierte Kenntniserfahrung
aufbauen, Strategie, ja, Blablabla, wenn du Netzwerkspezialist bist sollst du das haben,
Kenntnissesbrief, einschlägiger Software zum Management von Netzwerkkomponenten, wisst
ihr was bei sowas immer unglaublich praktisch ist, wenn da steht was die verwenden, das
machen viele nicht, wobei man sagen muss einschlägige Software, die Sache ist halt die, es gibt in
vielen Bereichen zwar einschlägige Software, aber das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab,
was du benutzt, also einschlägige Software, das kann sein, dass du dich mit einschlägiger
Software auskennst für die Sachen, die du früher verwendet hast, aber nicht unbedingt
jetzt mit den Netzwerkkomponenten, die verwenden und also, ja, also es ist immer sinnvoll da
hinzuschreiben, wenn man denn wirklich was will, also wenn die zum Beispiel jetzt sagen,
sie wollen Erfahrungen mit SolarWinds oder sowas oder SolarWinds, bespricht man das aus,
dieses Ding was letztens über seinen Update-Server Malware verteilt hat, SolarWinds IPAM oder
sowas, da solltest du es hinschreiben, Erfahrungen der Administration, ja, das ist, oh gut, das
würde ich dazuzählen, sichere Umgang, Skripterstellung, ja, würde ich auch, ausgeprägte Kommunikation
und Teamfähigkeit, ne, ich glaube das wird nicht funktionieren, also wenn du so hier
einen für findest, dann ist das sicherlich keiner, der gerne kommuniziert und Team,
der will eher seine Ruhe haben, ja ja, SolarWinds hat über den eigenen Update Malware verteilt,
SolarWinds IPAM News Malware, also guck mal, wenn es sogar in die Computerbild schreibt,
da kann doch eigentlich nichts mehr falsch sein, du musst dir zugeben, oder, da kannst
du eigentlich, kannst du eigentlich darauf vertrauen, ja, aber Heiser hat da auch drüber
geschrieben, also nicht so, dass die Computerbild darüber geschrieben hat, genau, die haben,
die haben über ihre Update-Server irgendwie Malware ausgeliefert, weil die gehackerment
wurden, oder ich weiß nicht, ob es über die Updates, ja ich glaube über die Update-Server,
auf jeden Fall über den SolarWinds Update haben die Malware mit ausgeliefert, das ist
ein Problem, was uns in nächster Zeit noch öfters bevorstehen wird, mit jeder Menge
Software, und wenn es mal einen großen App-Store trifft, ist es eh vorbei, analytisches Denken,
blablabla, Bereitschaft zur kontinuierlichen Fort- und Weiterbildung ist die Frage, ob
ihr da auch ein bisschen was für bezahlt, ich glaube die meisten Leute, die in der
Technik arbeiten, sind an aktuellen Entwicklungen und sonstigen Sachen durchaus interessiert,
das kommt so mit dem Beruf mit, also es gibt kaum einer, der das gelernt hat und sich dafür
interessiert und sagt, nee ab heute interessiert mich das nicht mehr, die Frage ist bloß eher,
wenn der dann mal sagt, hey wie siehts dann aus, ich hab da was neues gesehen, ich würd
gerne mir, was weiß ich, sag mal was einfach, ich würd mir einfach gerne mal nen, nen,
nen, nen, was weiß ich, Judemikurs dafür kaufen oder so, für 60 Euro, bezahlt ihr
mir das?
Und die dann sagen, nö, gibt's nicht, das ist das eigentliche Problem, aber wenn die
das machen, ist glaub ich die Bereitschaft da, als Familiengerechte, blablabla, oh, okay,
das machen sie aber in ihrer, ich will mich jetzt nicht in die Brennnesseln setzen, das
ist ja ein heiß diskutiertes Thema aktuell, aber dann sollten sie zumindest mal gucken,
was sie das einheitlich in ihrer Stellenanzeige schreiben, da sind sie sich ja selbst nicht
so ganz einig, wie das Ganze, wie das Ganze ist, was ist eigentlich die Diversity-Kompetenz,
darf man sich darunter vorstellen, also wenn jemand zu mir sagt, mal angenommen zu mir
kommt ein Kerl, der offensichtlich nach Kerl aussieht und er sagt zu mir, er möchte gerne
mit, äh, sie angesprochen werden, dann mach ich das, hab ich überhaupt keine Probleme
damit, ähm, aber im Umkehrschluss kann er nicht erwarten, dass ich das von mir aus
erkenne, so, so, so, so seh ich das, ja, wenn man Rücksicht erwartet, muss man selbst
auch ein bisschen Rücksicht nehmen, sodass die Leute das nicht direkt, äh, nicht direkt
alles immer auf den ersten Blick richtig machen, aber ich denke, wenn sich beide Seiten Mühe
geben, ist das kein Problem, wenn ein Kerl als Frau angeredet werden will, mach ich das,
hab ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit, aber wie gesagt, ob ich das von mir aus dann sofort
erkenne ist mir da was anderes, eher nicht, so, ähm, alles klar, Moment, also, wenn sich
einer bei euch bewirbt, dann solltet ihr doch wenigstens, die Euro 50 haben, ihm eine ordentliche
Absage zu schicken inklusive seiner Bewerbung, ich mein, man kann ja theoretisch drauf scheißen,
ja, aber, naja, aber ganz einfach zusätzlich, was zusätzlich, Moment, muss jetzt, Moment,
was, bitte, okay, das, das muss ich jetzt nochmal durchlesen, bitte senden Sie Ihre Bewerbung
nebstander auf dem Postweg bis zum 2.
August, und senden Sie Ihre Bewerbung in einem PDF, warum, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn
wieder, warum kann ich den nicht einfach auf ein PDF schicken und gut ist, was ist das
für ein Schwachsinn, das verstehe ich, keine Drucker, ja, dann solltet ihr sich halt am
Computer angucken, ja gut, wunderbar, kann man sich doch aber drauf bewerben, also wenn
man sich das wirklich geben will, wie gesagt, ich glaube, das ist eine äußerst undankbare
Stelle, aber kann man, kann man auch machen, bei 5MB raucht der E-Mail-Server ab, der E-Mail-Server
bzw. der Upload-Server bei der IHK ist abgeraucht, wo ich meine Abschlussprüfung hochgeladen
hab, meine Abschlussdokumentation und dann hat die IHK gesagt, sie haben es nicht bekommen,
obwohl ich noch die Bestätigungs-E-Mail hab, dabei ist ihr Server gecrashed, ja, hab ich
ein Video drüber gemacht, also was, was wollen die, ein Software-Engineer Photoshop, wo ist
das in, in Hamburg, ok, das kriegt man nur mit Premium angezeigt, alles klar, changing
the world, bla, bla, bla, bla, Photoshop Web-Frontend, boah, Web-Assembly-Photoshop, ey, das ist,
ey, wenn man, wenn man es drauf hat, ist das sicherlich kein schlechter Arbeitgeber, also
ich glaube, das ist wirklich was, was, wo man auch, wo man echt was vorzuzeigen hat,
in Hamburg geht Photoshop-Entwicklung anscheinend, das Web-Frontend von Photoshop, beziehungsweise
irgendeinen Web, Web-Fotoshop, Cloud, Cloud-Web-Fotoshop, keine Ahnung, so Leute, haben wir noch,
ach, hier paar denen wollte ich gucken, genau, also, im nächsten, im nächsten, ich wollte
mal gucken, ob die was Neues haben, im nächsten Stellenanzeigen-Video blende ich übrigens
dann auch die zwei Kommentare ein, von den, von den zwei Unternehmen, die geantwortet
haben auf meine Stellenanzeigen, die waren ja beide nicht so, nicht so hundertprozentig
glücklich darüber, ähm, ja, die haben wir uns das letzte Mal schon angeguckt, ich wollte
mal schauen, ob die was Neues haben, da habe ich nämlich letztens eine Werbung bekommen,
auf Twitter für, ich habe auf Twitter die Werbung bekommen, heure an, bei uns auf dem
Piraten-Schiff oder irgendwie sowas, und da ist mir aufgefallen, das haben wir uns schon
mal im Stream angeguckt, Backend-PHP-Developer, Infrastructure-Engineer, Frontend-Developer,
ok, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was man als Frontend und Infrastructure-Engineer braucht,
die zahlen bestimmt gut, glaube ich nicht, das ist irgendein Startup, die zahlen in
der Regel nicht gut, was, schau mal bei GetInIT, können wir machen, ja, das haben wir uns
schon mal angeguckt, ich, ich, ich finde es ja, ich, solche, solche Gruppenteam-Meetings
finde ich ja immer Hardcore-Cringe, vor allem wenn sie dann auch noch hier mit ihren Kappen,
aber vielleicht, ich, ich will jetzt da gar nichts so sehr Schlechtes drüber sagen, weil
vielleicht machen die Leute das echt freiwillig, es, und es ist ein Unterschied zwischen freiwillig
und freiwillig, also was ich, was ich meine ist, freiwillig muss es sein, also das ist
gesetzlich nicht ok, wenn ein Arbeitgeber sagt, du musst mit Piratenmütze arbeiten
oder so, geh mal von aus, das ist, aber es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen freiwillig
und freiwillig, freiwillig, das erste freiwillig ist, du wirst blöd angeguckt und dein Chef
sagt hier, warum haben sie das nicht gemacht, wenn du es nicht machst, und richtig freiwillig
ist, die Leute sind einfach davon überzeugt und finden es cool, und ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es bei denen echt so ist, dass die Leute davon überzeugt sind und das cool finden,
na gut, desinteressiert gucken ist bei solchen Meetings normal, wie willst du denn da auch
sonst gucken, das ist irgendwie, wir setzen uns mal alle in ein Meeting um Gruppenfoto
zu machen, das ist nicht sonderlich spannend, aber die sind auf jeden Fall agil und selbst
organisiert, ich glaube die sind gar nicht so übel, wir haben uns das letzte Mal das
schon eingeschaut, ich glaube die sind gar nicht so schlecht, und die hatten ja auch,
die hatten ja auch irgendwelche Schatzkisten im Büro stehen und sowas, haben sie doch
gezeigt, genau hier, also man muss sagen Büro, Büro ist eh ein bisschen zu viel gesagt,
das ist eine 2 Zimmer Wohnung mit Piraten-Theme und nicht sonderlich bequem aussehenden,
na wobei doch, doch, doch schon ganz nette, ich glaube halt, ich will ihn jetzt nicht
unrecht tun, aber ich hab so den doofen Eindruck, da geht Style über Substanz, das ist so krass
gestylt mit Palmen und Kanonen und sonst wie, ist halt die Frage, ob der Style dann, wisst
ihr wie ich mein, dass der Style dann nicht teurer ist als das was am Ende rauskommt,
kein Schimmer, ich glaube die sind gar nicht so übel, das haben wir uns das letzte Mal
schon angeguckt, ich fand das durchaus in Ordnung, das wurde nur für die Bilder gemacht,
kann sein, also was brauchen wir denn hier, Infrastructure-Engineer, Moment haben wir
uns das nicht das letzte Mal sogar schon angeguckt, genau das, das kommt mir bekannt vor und das
war auch, die Stellenanzeige war auch okay, Techradar, okay zeig mal her, oh jetzt, jetzt
wirds, jetzt wirds advanced hier, Hold, Assess, warum Assess, Assess, warum Assess, ah Assess,
ah verstehe, Assess, Alter, okay Hold, Assess, Try and Adopt, alles klar, was haben sie denn
hier am Start, also was, was sie schon benutzen, was soll ich jetzt, die Zahlen zuordnen, ach
ne hier stehts doch, Frontend, also Frontend, was benutzen sie, Chart.js, ESLint, JavaScript,
React, okay React, es ist zumindest, ich mein ich kenne mich mit React nicht gut aus, ich
bin eher der Vue.js Mensch, aber ist durchaus was modernes im Frontend am Start, gut das
sind alles so Sachen so, ja, also interessant sind hier eigentlich die drei Dinger, JavaScript,
React, Typescript, ja okay, JavaScript, React, Typescript, der Rest ist bla, welchen Package
Manager verwendet ist jetzt eine Sache von fünf Minuten, Chart.js ist jetzt auch kein
Hexenwerk und ESLint ist eigentlich auch ziemlich Standard, wobei ESLint braucht man eigentlich
nicht wenn man, so wie wir alle zusammen, selbstverständlich fehlerfreien und sich selbst
dokumentierten Code schreibt, dann braucht man nicht auch noch irgendwelche Formatierungssachen
überprüfen, das ist natürlich nur für Lowbrain Leute, für uns ist das nix, aber ist auch
Standard, so Apollo ist mega nice, CraftQL, das ist ein JavaScript CraftQL Framework,
also CraftQL und Apollo ist eines der geilsten Sachen die sich in letzter Zeit, in den letzten
paar Jahren so ausgedacht haben, das ist quasi wer es nicht kennt, ich versuch das mal zu
beschreiben, das ist SQL für JavaScript, also wenn du vom Frontend Sachen abfragen
willst, machst du jetzt keine Getrequests mehr, sondern machst quasi SQL Queries gegen
das Backend, es ist nicht wirklich SQL, es ist ein bisschen andere Sprache und es funktioniert
auch nicht so viel wie ein SQL, aber man kann sich so vorstellen, dass man quasi SQL abfragen
macht aus dem Frontend raus, das sieht ein bisschen, ja, das könnten auch einzelne Piratenschiffe
sein, Storybook, das kenne ich nicht, weiß ich nicht was, was ist Storybook, kennt das
jemand, Formic und Jup kenne ich auch nicht, Jup ist, Jup doch, Jup kenne ich, ist Jup
nicht der, der ist so ein Generator für, Generator für Formulare, das ist Formic wahrscheinlich
auch, Jup kok, Storybook kenne ich aber nicht, keine Ahnung, das sagt mir nichts, Redux,
das sagt mir was, habe ich aber noch nie was mitgemacht, das ist irgendein State Management
für React, also diesen Link da klicke ich garantiert nicht an, was auch immer das ist,
das sieht nicht vertrauenswürdig aus, ach das, jetzt weiß ich was es ist, ja das habe
ich schon mal in einem Video gesehen, sagt mir, sagt mir, aber soweit, habe ich noch
nicht verwendet, was haben die sonst noch, jQuery, ja manche Sachen wirst du nicht los,
manche Sachen wirst du nicht los, Kendo, UI, keine Ahnung, SCSS, warum, ist doch nice,
na gut, also das Wahnsinn, Infrastructure, haben sie Ansible, AWS, Bash, Cloudflare,
Data, Datadoc, das kennt jemand, oder benutzt das jemand auf der Arbeit, ich habe mir Datadoc
schon ein paar mal angeguckt und ich bin immer zu dem Schluss gekommen, es macht einen coolen
Eindruck, ist aber unglaublich teuer, deswegen habe ich mich da nie näher mit beschäftigt,
Docker, Fluent, Fluent, Fluent, die sagt mir nichts, GitLab, Continuous Integration,
Continuous Libre, New Relic, Engine X, Python, ok, das ist eigentlich alles relativ standard,
Ansible ist zum Server automatisch aufsetzen, AWS ist halt wahrscheinlich da wo ihr Cloud
Continuous läuft, Bash für irgendwelche Scripts und interaktive Sachen, Cloudflare, DDoS Protection,
Datadoc, Log Analyse, was ist bei irgendeinem Startup, irgendeinem Startup, die Leute suchen,
Fluent D sagt mir nichts, Engine X als Web Server, was war New Relic nochmal, ist das
auch so ein Metric Ding, wieso kein PowerShell, weil das keine kacke Windows Noobs sind, ist
doch ganz einfach, ich weiß man kann PowerShell auch unter Linux installieren, aber es macht
keiner, der beiverstanden ist, ok, Wacom ist on hold, Backend, bla bla bla, ok, das ist
PHP Zeug, da habe ich keine Ahnung von, da habe ich keinen Schimmer von PHP, Codeception,
keine Ahnung, doch Composer kenne ich den Package meiner Tafel, PHP, Gazl, HTTP, noch
nie gehört, Monolog, noch nie gehört, PHP, ja gut, PHP.de, das PHP Dependency Injection
oder was ist PHP.de, das klingt wie ein Testing Framework für PHP, GraphQL Beste, Grunt,
gitt, das war eines der schlimmsten Tools, die ich je verwendet habe, Cent sagt mir noch
irgendwas, auch in PHP gedönnt, aber sieht ziemlich modern, Webstack mäßig aus, gut,
müssen wir uns jetzt nicht zu nahe angucken, haben wir uns letztes Mal schon angeschaut,
also, habe ich im Chat irgendwas übersehen an Stellen anzeigen, ja die da, Karyas Ghost,
Unlimited Paid Vacation ist, wird nicht so sein, das kannst du vergessen, das ist ein
typischer Trick, um einen Vorteil fortzutäuschen, der keiner ist, das wird nämlich vollendermaßen
laufen, wenn du, also Unlimited Paid Vacation führt, da gibt es sogar Untersuchungen dazu,
führt dazu, dass die Leute weniger Urlaub nehmen, als ihnen eigentlich sonst zustehen
würde, klingt erstmal widersprüchlich, ne, also die werben mit, du bekommst quasi so
viel Urlaub, du bekommst so vielen bezahlten Urlaub, wie du willst, wie kann das dazu führen,
dass die Leute im Endeffekt sogar weniger Urlaub nehmen, naja, das liegt daran, dass
das einen gewissen sozialen Druck erzeugt, wir müssen uns das jetzt mal angucken, keine
Ahnung, ob das damit gemeint ist, in dem der anscheinend, was ich jetzt darunter verstehe,
aber da hab ich schon in der Vergangenheit einige Artikel zugelesen und Berichte drüber
gehört, dass es eine Zeit lang mal gerade in den USA im Trend war, sowas zu behaupten,
dass man Unlimited Paid Leave und sowas hat und Vacation und in Wirklichkeit hat das
dazu geführt, dass die Leute weniger Urlaub genommen haben, weil es so quasi einen Wettbewerb
gab, Wettbewerb war, im Endeffekt, wer, also du kannst es dir dann nicht mehr erlauben
eigentlich die Firma hängen zu lassen, so nach dem Motto und das ist so ein typischer
Fall von, sieht auf den ersten Blick gut aus, muss es aber gar nicht sein, da gibt es immer
mal wieder Anfragen an IT Abteilung als eine Person, doch, so hab ich ja noch nie gehört,
wie viele komischen, wie viele komischen Jobportale gibt es eigentlich, mir hat eben vorhin auch
schon einer was geschrieben, Get in IT oder nicht, hab ich gesehen, ich mag ehrlich gesagt,
dass, dass, dass Golem Jobs, weil die sind da, das sind die schlechtesten eigentlich,
also wer auf Golem Jobs inseriert, der hat ja meistens nicht so viel zu bieten, so kann
man das auch sehen, ok, wo haben wir jetzt hier gerade, hier das, also zeigt man ja,
Product Engineer, Ghost, warte mal, was war denn Ghost nochmal, Ghost ist diese, ist Ghost
nicht dieses Static Blog Generator Ding, Static Website Generation, ich bin mir grad nicht
ganz sicher aus dem Kopf raus, was Ghost ist, ne, oder, das ist immer toll, wenn man wissen
will, was ist es eigentlich, Ghost is just an amazing experience, ja super, ich will
da wissen, was es ist, ist das wie Hugo, ich glaub, das ist so was ähnliches, ja versus
WordPress, genau, das ist irgendeine, irgendeine Blog Static Generator Plattform, hey, ach
so, ich dachte, das ist mein Gehalt, da hätte ich mir auch mal kurzzeitig überlegt, ob ich
mich nicht bewerbe, aber, die drei können wir auch weglassen, ist auch ok, DuckDuckGo,
ich glaub, DuckDuckGo gehört nicht zu einem der Largest Organizations, aber ich benutze
gerne DuckDuckGo als Suchmaschine mittlerweile, neben Google, ok, die sind auch alle super
glücklich, alle mega happy, das ist mir zu viel Text, ok, ich bin ja, ich bin ja begeistert,
dass sie den gleichen Trick machen, wie in Deutschland bei den Stellenanzeigen, bei
uns steht dann auch immer so was wie ein marktübliches Gehalt oder, oder, über, was ich auch schreibe,
überdurchschnittliches Gehalt und sowas, guckst schon wieder nach neuen Stellen, wir
haben das letzte Mal vor zwei Monaten oder so geguckt, außerdem muss ich endlich mal
ein Video zumachen, hätte mal wieder Zeit, aber dazu brauche ich mehr Crap, ich nehme
ja immer ein paar gute Stellenanzeigen absichtlich mit rein, aber das lustigste ist natürlich,
wenn man Mist vorstellen kann, Work From Anywhere, das finde ich immer gut, wenn man das schreibt,
ja das ist gut, das wird übrigens glaube ich auch noch ein Problem für Apple, die
Apple Leute haben ja immer noch ziemlich interne Kämpfe was Home Office angeht, Hardware,
New Laptop, Bam, Co-Working, ok, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf, muss man gleich mit
den Leuten in den Urlaub fahren oder was, reicht das nicht, wenn man miteinander arbeitet,
muss man gleich zusammen in den Urlaub fahren, letzten Freitag vor dem Monat ist frei, excellent,
das heißt 30. wäre bei denen frei, ok, ja gut zwei Wochen ist ja nichts, das wird dazu
führen, dass die Leute zwei Wochen nehmen und nicht mehr, das finde ich gut, was ist
denn ein Pay Review, ob du weniger bekommst, es klingt jetzt natürlich erst mal positiv
so nach dem Motto, es wird einmal im Jahr geguckt ob du noch genug bekommst, ob das
angemessen ist, mal gucken vielleicht geht es ja auch nach hinten los und die sagen eigentlich
verdienst du viel zu viel, das ist aber eine gute Sache, dass das automatisch passiert,
bei uns muss man immer den Leuten auf den Keks gehen, das nervt, eigentlich fände ich
das durchaus sinnvoll, wenn Regelmitte, das sollte eigentlich eines der, es sollte Mit-Aufgabe
ehrlich gesagt von Management sein, mein Manager heißt ja im Prinzip, dass man Sachen koordiniert
und plant, da sollte sowas auch dazu gehören, das finde ich kommt bei uns ein bisschen zu
kurz und auch da wo ich arbeite, so du musst den Leuten immer selbst auf den Keks gehen,
das ist ein blocked friendly Office, naja kann man bestimmt machen, die sind bestimmt super
agile, Achtung Leute, Flashbang, ich mags digital, ich auch, also wir sind authentisch digital,
ich kundener und erfolgreich alles klar die kenne ich nicht weiß ich warum mir das jemand
gerade geschickt hat das ist das irgendwie so ein headhunter laden oder so sagt mir
überhaupt nichts sie mögen auf jeden fall ungerade ausgerichtet richtete bilder ja das
gefühl habe ich auch dass das ui von manchen anwendungen auf diese art entsteht random von
zwei leuten auf der wand gemalt das glaubst du ist das bei microsoft mittlerweile auch
ok da kann ich nichts zu sagen hipster hacker was für ein ding hipster hacker hustler was ist da
los bist du auch ein hipster hacker oder hast du ok ecker wir sind richtig hacker man action hier
wie heißt das piraten unter pirate ship von schülern praktikanten bis zum sehen
projekten manche ja sucht er nicht vielleicht konkret irgendwas die male sap das mit zu
unübersichtliche karriere ok zeige ja also ich ne da blicke ich nicht durch die seite
ist mir zu zu zu big brain ssap richtiger pence jamp videoshow oh nee nee leute ich will
das video nicht gucken das ist cringe die solche videos soll ich soll mir das nein das gucken wir
nicht nein gut jett sagt auch nein dann gucken wir das auch nicht erst den anfangen ok den
anfangen die ersten zehn sekunden und wenn es cringe ist mache ich direkt aus
ich bin die susi und ich bin bei der dorsus projekt managerin und leite
srp projekte srp gehen wir weg projekte seit 2014 susi sucht ja was anderes srp muss das sein
denn ich habe schon während meinem studium das war 2006 2009 für eine kleine ausgründung der
dort so was als werksstudent gearbeitet und habe woanders gearbeitet und dann dachte ich mir das
ist hipster hacker hast du ich dachte da kommt jetzt sonst was und auf 35 stunden ist aber
immer noch eine anzahl an stunden wo man irgendwie projekte 35 stunden viel zu viel ihr wisst ich
persönlich arbeite nur 30 stunden das reicht mir warum lebst du design thinking ok das muss
ich jetzt wissen ich weiß gar nicht was das sein soll das sagt kls auch immer du brauchst
das richtige mindset du musst du musst du musst hustlen und auf den mount Everest mindset das ist
das allerwichtigste das heißt man muss eigentlich von nichts eine ahnung haben man braucht nur das
richtige mindset was darauf ausgerichtet ist dass man den kunden und sein problem oder den nutzer
und sein problem gut versteht um dann lösungen zu finden ok das heißt im endeffekt user designer
programmer meme weil wir wissen dieses bild mit dieser schaukel ihr erkennt das bild
das da
ja so kommt auf das läuft sein im endeffekt raus
ich weiß ich gibt es irgendjemand gibt es gibt es irgendjemand der kundenanfragen wirklich
versteht in diesem prozess ist ganz stark verankert dieses dieses scheitern und aus
fehlern lernen das finde ich gut geht quasi nicht den weg das finde ich also wenn man es
denn auch macht man fährt gegen aber in der regel mal ganz ehrlich mal ganz mal ganz im
ernst wenn was überhaupt nicht klappt dann muss man das nicht erst 80 prozent machen das merkt
man schon relativ schnell und geht den weg noch mal neu ist ein ansatz für komplexe probleme ich
finde das übrigens gut die lösungsansatz nicht sofort auf der hand liegt und da kann eben eine
teamleistung mit einem team mit vielen unterschiedlichen fähigkeiten helfen warum haben die eine zweite
kamera warum muss ich von der seite gefilmt werden albino gar nicht für den sub das glaube
ich nicht das glaube ich nicht das glaube ich nicht das glaube ich nicht das das das nein das
glaube ich nicht es sei denn sie füllt gerne excel tabellen aus jeder tag sieht auch anders
aus als projekt manager und das ist unheimlich motivierend immer wieder eine neue herausforderung
zu haben okay bei der dotso ist bin ich der hasler weil ich nicht nur meine
eigenen projekte unterstütze und mein eigenes team sondern weil ich im gesamten unternehmen
als mentor arbeite und 35 stunden das sie gut aufgegleist werden und dass sie auch strategisch
aufgegleist okay ich weiß vielleicht ein bisschen ich weiß vielleicht ein bisschen gemein aber das
was sie gesagt hat mit dass man auch mal scheitert das ist das was ich glaube ich auch in einem der
letzten videos erzählt habe ich finde das gar nicht schlecht ich finde das vom ansatz ja gar
nicht schlecht das wird auch meiner mann nach zu wenig gemacht es ist wichtig dass man sachen
ausprobiert natürlich spricht nichts dagegen dass man sachen auch versuchen soll soweit zu
planen wie man es kann aber man muss auch zugeben können wenn man sich verrannt hat was zumindest
bei uns auf der arbeit ich kann jetzt ja nicht unbedingt für alle sprechen aber ich glaube
das trifft auf mir auch viele zu bei uns auf der arbeit ist es so wir verrennen uns oftmals in was
und können da nicht zugeben dass von uns verrannt haben und ziehens durch bis zum schluss und es
kommt in den abs abgrund tief grottenschlechter kacke bei raus weil weil niemand möchte also quasi
sein gesicht verlieren so nach dem motto man hat kacke gemacht das ist ein problem die auch
jegliche oder viel viel innovationen der irgendwie rausnimmt ja 11 korn gut du kannst du könntest
sie natürlich gerne im chat posten aber ich denke man will es nicht sonst könnte man es zu
erzuordnen sonst können wir uns cringe stelle angucken also ja dann wenn es postet dann gucken
wir uns hier an cringe cringe stelle massive cringe stelle ok es ist es ist die webseite
ist eine asp.net anwendung das finde ich das finde ich schon mal paints jam dot source ja die
habe ich gerade angeguckt ich habe aber nicht durchgeblickt wo ich die stellen anzeigen finde
ok da geht schon los leute nur weiß und männlich und nicht deutsch da fehlt eindeutig das d anzeige
anzeige diversity anzeige ist raus wenn das die falschen leute auf twitter mitkriegen dann
werdet ihr gecancelt dann ist vorbei ein der schweiz ok dann verstehe sie denn der schweiz
der schweiz muss das nicht sein ja ja die seite habe ich gefunden mit karriere und ich glaube
ich habe mich richtig runter gescrollt jetzt sehe ich es auch können wir gleich können wir gleich
gucken ok also die übliche geschichte mit wir sind die geilsten wahrscheinlich am anfang ist ja
immer so das ist ja ich verstehe dass es bvl technischen dienstleisterin heißt aber ich
finde es ließ sich besser wenn man schreibt der zentrale dienstleister aber es ist die schweiz
vielleicht sehen die das anders für die rund 80 in und aus ich weiß nicht wer die marty gruppe
ist ok sie berät schützt mit jeden fall in den bereich informatik finanzen personalversicherung
einkaufen in consulting consulting den denken sie in unsere welt ein wo großes geplant und
gebaut wird werden sie teil der marty familie etwas von familie steht finde ich das immer
cringe bringen sie ihr know-how ihren spirit und enthousiasmus zu uns und bauen sie mit uns an
der zukunft wir suchen zur verstärkung service ok genau erst mal die mega motivierende ansprache
und dann service desk don't cry so much sieben monate für den sub also ict supporter ict
das was schweizerisches ich habe keine ahnung was das ist ict habe ich schon nie gehört die
abkürzung information communications technology sollte man eigentlich erwarten dass das was
total gängiges ist aber habe ich noch nie gehört so in der also quasi auf deutsch computer krab
für diese aufgabe sind verantwortlich sie helfen unsere zahlreichen benutzer in tägliche service desk
dazu nehmen sie support anfangen störungs meldung entgegen ist service desk finden und
implementieren sie dank ihrem ict wissen selbschen gelösung workarounds teilweise service desk kommt
kommt auf den service desk an standard dienstleistung stellen sie auf hab gerade gelesen kinderwunsch
das ergibt aber wenig sinn standard dienstleistung stellen sie auf kundenwunsch und nach anleitung
selbstständig bereit das bedeutet es ruft dich jemand an er sagt er will wird installiert haben
und du installierst ihm wird verstehe ich darunter wahlweiten sie im team die schwierigen
außergewöhnlichen fälle sind auch meistens die nervigen fälle gerade im support beschreiben
sie die lösung in der wissensdatenbank dokumentation ich sage es doch immer wieder das muss alles
selbsterklärend sein dann braucht man auch keine dokumentation auf beratet dokumentation
beraten sie unsere kunden hard und software bereich entwickeln sie sich und das team weiter
ja das schreiben immer alle und man weiß nie so genau was damit gemeint ist ja das ist ein
internes wiki ziemlich sicher oder wenn es noch schlimmer wenn es kein internes wiki ist dann
ist es irgendwie ein internes knowledge base system was man sich gekauft hat was irgendwie nur
fünf leute auf der welt verwenden und abgrundtief kacke ist wenn man glück hat ist es konfluenz
das kann man auch halbwegs verwenden aber ich habe schon einige gesehen die haben sich also
das heißt einige ich habe es bei zwei leden bis es sind ja einige bisher gesehen dass man sich
einmal ein total unausgegorenes nicht weiterverwendet das knowledge base system gekauft hat was
irgendwie gefühlt außer uns auf der welt nicht nicht nicht einer verwendet hat das war halt
dermaßen kacke und bei bei einem anderen habe ich gesehen man hat versucht selbst was zu
programmieren jetzt kommt der hammer man hat man hat versucht eine eine wissens datenbank
selbst zu programmieren auf jetzt haltet euch fest lotus notes basis da war vorbei was ist
das lotus notes ist von ibm ne ne und wir wissen das jetzt mittlerweile ich sag mal früher war
das von ibm eigentlich ein system was war ursprünglich für emails gedacht war aber
was dann zu einem eigenen zu einer eigenen an zu einem komplett eigenen anwendungs framework
mit datenbank und allem aufgeblasen wurde es ist der teufel ja das stimmt kommt kommt in die nähe
hat hcl weiß ich mal wer das ist wer ist hcl hcl vita aci vita kenne ich das singen saft
aber das ist hcl flor wasserstoff ne lotus notes hat sie er notes
wer ist hcl technologies a peta vor microsoft support jetzt ok dann ist das dann ist der support
wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer als vorher ok also was haben die denn hier zu bieten sie helfen
unseren zahlen reichen benutzer in den moment das hatten wir doch gerade schon also was sie dazu
mitbringen sie sind eine alti quereinsteigerin mit ausbildung und erfahrung im ict bereich oder
informatikerin ist das ist das in den schreibt man das in der schweiz so dass man so quasi die die
die generischen sachen als weiblich beschreibt ist das so ein schweizer ding seit neuestem ist das
so das ist das ist quasi informatiker innen bei uns ist bei bei schweizer informatikerin
da wenigstens mal die schweizer kommt konsequent wenigstens mal die schweizer konsequent da weiß
man wenigstens wie man schreiben soll oder informatikerin efz efz leute das ding besteht
aus ich habe keine ahnung was das ist eisenbahnfreunde zollerbahn ich glaube die sind damit
glaube ich nicht gemeint die eisenbahnfreunde zollerbahn ausbildung eidgenössisches fähigkeitszeugnis
jetzt das ist jetzt kommt jetzt kommen die schweizer dinger habe ich keine ahnung da
vorne patrick ist auch schon weg also sie stehen mit microsoft android und ios auf und gehen mit
trucker firewall und ip zu ok das ist ein harter pains champsatz das ist das ist das ist wirklich
pains champsicht richtiger pain vor allem gibt es überhaupt gar keinen sinn erst mal trucker tinte
unter der beddecke ok freude an mindestens einer fremdsprache denn sie sprechen sehr gut deutsch
oder französisch stimmt in schweiz ja und können sich in der anderen sprache problem also das heißt
im endeffekt wenn du deutsch kannst sollst du französisch kennen wenn du französisch kannst
dort deutsch können die schweizer haben pech da reden einige französische sie können in london
den weg zum ok das könnte ich auch dass das könnte ich auch aber ich hätte keinen bock den
ganzen tag englisch englisch zu reden das einzige problem was ich dabei hätte ist zu wissen wie man
das ausspricht da würde ich aber einfach in google eingeben oder kriegen wir das schon erzählt
covent garden covent garden und dann würde ich google maps nehmen und sagen london easy und da
wüsste ich wie ich hinkomme aber fragen fragen könnte ich auch nachdem ich wüsste wie man den
kram ausspricht das finde ich das finde ich von der idee ja nicht verkehrt das sagt nämlich genau
aus also das sagt genauer aus ansonsten also normalerweise steht drin so nach dem motto
englisch auf bla bla bla level oder englisch fließen oder hier weiß man wenigstens was
gemeint ist ja also du solltest mit ein bisschen gestotter was auf englisch sagen können und die
antwort verstehen we are all sitting in one boat sie haben ein geschick um in angespannten
situationen ruhig und kompetent zu sprechen das habe ich nicht wenn ich angespannt bin
bin ich mal rege ich mich meistens über irgendwas auf und das ist selten ruhig und kompetent dann
bald ist boomer bett gezeigt ihre empathy erlaubt ihnen zu verstehen dass die benutzer
unserer wichtigsten auftraggeber sind und handeln entspricht die empathy hört irgendwann auf wenn
der user einem zum zwanzigste mal auf den sack geht ok sie finden eitel so wichtig dass sie wissen
ok überspringen wir das war es heißt die sagen man braucht ein eitel zertifikat je nachdem wie
ernst sie das nehmen ist es im helpdesk gar nicht so realitätsfremd finde ich also wenn die das sehr
stark eitel prozessmäßig unterwegs sind ist es nicht verkehrt wenn du zumindest die ganzen
buzzwords und und und abkürzung und dinger verstehst ja flinzeln sehe ich auch so das ist
gar nicht so schlecht so sagt so painstamp ist die anzeige gar nicht also das finde ich painstamp
aber der rest ist doch in ordnung ein spannendes arbeitsumfeld mit breitem einsatzgebiet und
tätigkeit falls sie mit einem eine größere on-premise und cloud it umgebung vorwiegend
auf microsoft also es heißt azur wahrscheinlich vermute ich mal weil was soll sonst damit gemeint
sein escherkram und und offline windows fortschrittliche anstellungsbedingungen
was ist denn damit gemeint gibt keine schläge mehr keine sklavenhaltung was in fortschrittliche
anstellungsbedingungen meinen die damit sie bezahlen gut aus ihrer sicht das ist das gegenstück zu
deutschen stellen anzeigen wo da drin steht ein marktübliches gehalt oder sowas wahrscheinlich
sie sind von 14 stunden dark auf zehn stunden darunter so gestaltungsmöglichkeit einer branche
im wandel der digitalisieren also ich muss sagen ich persönlich finde die stellen anzeige gar
nicht so painstamp ich kann mir vorstellen wenn man da selbst arbeitet und irgendwie das mit
bekommt und so dann ist vielleicht ein bisschen mehr cringe heute meine tastatur ist kaputt jetzt
geht sie wieder ich habe gerade ich habe gerade einsen getippt hat nicht da hat nichts passiert
geht es geht überhaupt nicht wenn ich einsen tippe muss gefährlich sein kommen ja also das
einzige was ich richtig richtig painstampig finde ist das hier aber ansonsten ist doch ist doch ok
so was haben die kommen wir gehen ich gucke jetzt noch mal 603 29 frankfurt genau zeige ich ja
golem jobs da ist immer so viel müll das ok dann gucke ich mir das noch mal aus dem chat an
also anwendungs informatiker mvd ich finde das ich finde okay der witz ist vorbei ich muss den
witz nicht jedes mal bringen was in deutschland also zeigt mal her was ist das das nervt
webdesigner erst mal anzeige raus hier also was macht die forster group 70
jahre den entscheidend technologischen vorsprung bla bla bla bla bla ok sehr uninteressant
und das ist das ist ja abfahrt pur dieses reinfade ding zur verstärkung unserer
hessischen anwendungsinfo ein anwendungs informatiker das ist eine kombination die
habe ich so noch nicht gelesen ist ein programm und was wollen die denn überhaupt haben agiles
entwickeln das ist ja mein zweiter vorname quasi agiles entwickeln betreuen und dokumentieren
unsere anwendung schon wieder warum verschwenden die alle ihre zeit mit dokumentieren die sollen
ordentlich programmieren und gut ist unsere anwendung software schrittstellen programmierung
erp crm fibo ok ja mit sein muss betreuung und erweitern ok normalerweise würde ich jetzt
aufhören zu lesen scare point und der schütze beim aufbau einer unternehmensweine applikation
zum gehoff basis von schaer point ok gut sie können ja machen was sie wollen wenn sie
schaer point was sollen sie schaer point machen ich weiß gar nicht mal ehrlich gesagt ob
schaer point nur gut oder schlecht ist für das was man da so macht ich weiß nur dass
ich es definitiv im leben nicht administrieren möchte beratung von kunden in house sowie
durchführen und umsetzten projekts ins incident schreibt man das echt tatsächlich natürlich
schreibt man das so ich sehe jeden tag tickets wo das drin steht irgendwie war ich grad
brain lacked incident und change management entwickeln testen und sicherstellen des produktiven
betriebs anwendung die suchen doch was versuchen die denn jetzt eigentlich genau so richtig
so richtig schlau helpline tickets wie kommst du auf helpline wir hatten mal helpline helpline
war eines der schlechtesten und beschissensten systeme die ich je gesehen habe hatte jemand
von euch schon mal die große ehre helpline als ticketsystem zu benutzen alter helpline
heute ich zeige euch das mal wohlgemerkt windows windows client only das ist cancer helpline
alter moment aber ich muss euch mal ich muss euch ich muss euch ein paar bilder von zeigen
es ist das schlimmste ist wirklich hier so sieht das aus guckt euch an
guckt euch das an guckt euch das an oh pains champ alter monka es das erste bild das ist
das neue web interface glaubst du gar nicht das kenne ich nicht das neu ich kenne nur
die alte anwendung dieser so aus so so wpwpwpf ding war das richtig aber richtiger trash
einfach nur mega trash gewesen helpline ist das in wishlist du ja das ist so halbe halbe
das ist im ticketsystem wo du aber ziemlich viel selbst erweitern kannst es ist richtig
eklig gewesen und was bei helpline witzig war wenn ich ein ticket genommen habe und
bin in urlaub gegangen konnte niemand das andere das ticket nehmen weil ich das ticket
erst wieder freigeben musste und sowas welches ticketsystem nutzt ihr auf der arbeit wir
haben wir haben gira gira gira alter gira was übrigens gar nicht so heißt glaube es
ist irgendwie ein japanisches wort was was man gira gira oder so ausspricht man spricht
es nicht man spricht es nicht hier aus ach was weiß ich oh noch noch noch ein job ok
gucken wir uns gleich anschauen oh leute gleich ist bettgezeit gleich ist bettge angesagt
ok mal schnell schnell hier weiter durchgucken confluence ist auch von gira nein confluence
und gira sind beide von atlasien gira ist ein ticketsystem also was wollen die dann
bla bla bisher ist mir nicht so ganz klar was die eigentlich für leute suchen also was
jetzt das schwerpunkt ist verstehe ich noch nicht so genau ok kenntnisse in oop sprachen
da hat die die personalabteilung aber wieder zugeschlagen beim erstellen dieser stellenanzeige
kenntnisse in oop sprachen wie wäre es denn mal zu sagen welche oop das kann meinetwegen
auch delfi sein also das ist bescheuert grundkenntnisse in msql geübte umgang mit entwicklungstools
ja mit welchen denn sagt halt was sagt halt was das ist so eine bescheuerte aussage geübter
umgang mit entwicklungstools was welche da gibt es 100.000 das ist total uns unsinnig
das überhaupt zu schreiben notpad plus plus grundzüge des entwicklens in heterogenen
system umgeben windows linux obunto und windows ok ja endlich mal einer der obunto surfer
verwenden zu wenigstens die richtige wahl fähigkeit robusten und wachbaren quelco zu
erstellen ok zuverlässigkeit kreativität gute deutsch englische ehrlich gesagt ich
hätte absolut keine ahnung was die von mir wollen also erstens was soll ich da machen
was wollen die von mir genau das ist total nicht sagen einfach nur komplett nicht sagen
die wissen es wahrscheinlich selber nicht was die wollen anrufen und klären das könnte
man machen aber ich bin der meinung wenn jemand eine stellenanzeige erstellt dann soll er
die wenigstens ordentlich erstellen dass du weißt was der haben was der wenigstens dass
du das was die von dir wollen also das kann ich sagen so jetzt gucken wir uns da schnell
den an markt ist das wurde vorn ne sieht von den farben her ein bisschen aus wie wo da
vorn bettgetheim ich merke schon bettke bettke ist angesagt kann man wirklich den ganzen
tag so gerade auf einem würfel sitzen und was machen die mit diesem notebook da die
sieht auch gar nichts von der entfernung drauf äußerst bequem ja ok das ist so ein super
agiles bild wie sie immer alle haben das ist ja das ist ja aktuell normal dass du so dass
du so super agile arbeitsgruppen haben muss also ich mache es musik wieder
ok also wenn sie eine neue technologie klare ziele vielfältige projektfelder zusammenarbeit
mit internationalen unternehmen aus der konsumgüterbranche das alles finden sie spannend um ehrlich
zu sein also die spannung hält sich in grenzen das alles finden sie bei uns wunderbar als
cloud engineer steigen sie bei der markant business to business integration ein um gemeinsam
service für lieferanten und händler zu kreieren und zu etablieren dort source please ok mach
ich mache danach auch noch dort source obwohl ich dann bettke nicht ins bett kommen hier
chat ist dran schuld wenn ich morgen nicht wach bin auf der arbeit sie entwickeln lösung
um alle daten entlang der wertschätzung blabla blabla blabla blabla blabla blabla blabla
ok weiter bewerben sie sich also was wollen sie denn haben cloud engineer mwd nach gottseidank
wieder markant services in oft oft ich habe offenbach gelesen als wer bei mir um die erke
vollzeit und zu besetzen und sie verbessern bestehende systeme wie sieht die seite eigentlich
normal aus vor flash flash bang alle die verbessern bestehen die konzeption neue features blabla
blabla blabla entwickeln software blabla blabla sie übernehmen kornier mein was suchen
sie noch mal den cloud engineer ja ok wenn man es schreibt da meinetwegen sie überführen
mehrheitlich on-premise betriebene da ist bindestrich zu viel oder ich bin ich will
jetzt nicht den rechtschreib nazi machen aber oder stimmt das justin brian dankeschön
für den sub in die cloud ok das heißt im endeffekt du legst 100 vms an und kopierst
alles von offline zu online so wird es wahrscheinlich laufen so sollte man keinen cloud umzug machen
aber so läuft wahrscheinlich e-bewerbungs profil erfolgreich abgeschoss das studium
fundierte berufserfahrung im bereich softwareentwicklung und systemadministration ja was wollt ihr
denn jetzt haben wollt ihr die software entwickler haben oder dann ab bzw also wenn man nicht
gerade so halbe sachen wie ich macht schon seit den letzten paar jahren dann hat man
in der regel erfahr tiefgreifende erfahrung in dem oder in dem gute allgemeine programmier
kenntnisse ja ok erfahrung im umgang mit ci cd system zb github auch ok kenntnisse
in der anwendung von microservices kenntnisse in der anwendung von microservices ja da müsst
ihr ein bisschen spezifischer werden das ist ja auch sehr nicht sachend krelax 19 monat
tragische für den hyper subscription ja single point of truth spot und stateless heute ich
muss euch sagen das ist mir neu das habe ich in dem zusammenhang noch nie gehört und ich
habe schon und ich habe schon einige buzzwords und so wir gucken uns ja auch öfter stellenanzeigen
aber das kenne ich noch nicht das single point of truth spot gibt sogar ein wikipedia eintrag
zu
ah eine globale datenbank oder so das könnte man auch einfach schreiben
das ist zu unbuzzword mäßig wenn man schreibt man hat eine übergreifende datenbank
kenntnisse im zusammenhang mit cloudtechnik geblieben ist azure docker compose also das
sind schon das sind schon drei äußerst unterschiedliche sachen doch komposed ist ein lokales nochmal
orchestrierung oder nicht mal ein lokales automatisierungstool kopanete ist eher was
richtung skalierung und azure ist eine hosting oder eine plattform also sehr unterschiedliche
ja ok aber wenn sie das wollen das das also ich kenne ich kenne saas und pass und was
neuerdings auch ganz ganz beliebte ist das infrastructure as code aber was ist denn everything
as code was ist denn wenn ich mal aufs klo muss ist das dann auch ja das ist auch code der
war schlecht ich gebe es zu ja everything as code leidenschaft für entwicklung richtig
dead jokes ja richtige page ich hab dead jokes ich weiß ist gut mitarbeiter mitarbeiter
as code code as code plattform erste plattform kommt dann als nächstes leidenschaft für
entwicklung und betrieb von service im umfeld der konsumergutbranche warum schreiben die
immer sowas gibt es wirklich irgendjemand der der vom rechner sitzt und sagt ich würde
so gern mal meine leidenschaft für entwicklung und betrieb von services im umfeld der konsumgüter
branche ausleben das ist so was du fängst dann da an und ja die stellen dafür was bereit
aber mir persönlich ist das doch scheißegal für was es am endeffekt ist zumal ich muss
mich damit ja auch gar nicht großartig identifizieren natürlich nicht nicht und chat bin ich der
einzige wo das so ist ja bettke ja ich weiß ich weiß richtig richtig over over time bettke
erfahrung in der agilen arbeitsweise hier ist schon mal das wichtigste da fühle ich
mich wie zu hause wir bieten arbeitgeberzuschuss zur betrieblichen alt das ist gut kostenfreie
getränke das steht da zwar immer dabei aber soll ich euch mal sagen also wenn man vor
ort sein muss finde ich es eigentlich ein unding wenn es dort keine kostenlose getränke
gibt das sollte wirklich standard sein du willst doch dass die leute nicht umkippen
gratis leidungswasser aber wenn das schon flexibel arbeitszeit moderne arbeitsplatzumgebung
das ist das sind nicht so viele vorteile der erste schritt bewerbung schicken verwandeln
sie ihre neugier entaufbruch ok so und jetzt gucke ich schnell noch mal bei dot source
weil irgendjemand gesagt ich soll unbedingt mal dot source gucken karriere ach da sind
die stellenanzeigen meine güte das hätte es aber kaum noch mehr verstecken können
du musst ja erst mal drei stunden runter runter scrollen bis du die stellenanzeigen
findest hier eine auswahl unserer aktuellen top stellen ok senior salesforce die bei pence
champ entwickler der pence champ selten pence champ p.a.p. jawoll office manager java script
entwickler java developer technik p.a.p. magento entwickler node gs entwickler cloud entwickler
ok der p.a.p. entwickler will was haben magento shopware typo 3 das sagt mir alles noch was
aber laminas kenne ich nicht symphony sagt mir auch noch was web stetige optimierung der
entwicklungsprozesse bla bla bla bla sehr gute grenzen od was ist ein od oop wird mir noch
was an was ist od p.a.p. od meinen die op und haben sich verschrieben od objekt orientiertes
design ok das wird selten verwendet wissen im bereich datenbank bla bla bla liest sich
doch ok spannende projekte getränke flatrate obstkörper süßfach das gefährlich das ist
gefährlich ich vermute mal op und od ist das gleiche regelmäßige teams event ok leute
ich bin weg wupp wupp lief wupp lief regelmäßige teams event office power wird ja noch schlimmer
nicht nur regelmäßige teams event auch noch office parties hör mir auf ich nee nee nee
es ist für mich schon wieder ganz grausam also wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich das lese regelmäßige
teams event office parties familiäres feeling ist vorbei ich will da arbeiten ich will nicht
mit euch befreundet sein und und ich will nicht dass der chef mich auf seine hochzeit einlädt
ich will da einfach nur arbeiten ja bla bla bla hipster hacker schon wieder schon wieder
einer o man ist aber nicht verkehrt ich glaube die sind gar nicht so übel ich finde das
nicht schlecht also der rest die restliche sachen machen doch ganz guten eindruck das
ist aber das ist so eine persönliche abneigung von mir ihr wisst dass ich prinzipiell alle
anderen menschen nicht mag außer den chat und den chat mag ich auch nicht immer kommt
auf den chat und den tag an ja ich bin familiäres feeling immer immer blöd wenn man das schreibt
ist das labern die bei uns auf der arbeit auch ich denke mir so ja ja solang es für
euch vorteile bringt erzählt ihr das aber sobald es in irgendeiner art und weise drauf
ankommt dass ihr mal was machen müsst dann ist das mit familie relativ schnell vorbei
ja die sind die sind familiär solange du dann sagst ja ok ich arbeite auch mal einem
tag wo ich eigentlich nicht müsste und so was aber sobald du was von denen willst sind
sie nicht mehr familiär das ist das ist blödsinn das sollen diese ist das einfach blödsinn
gelaber das labern zu alle
mit dem chat ganz schön dran das lese ich jetzt nicht für die ganzen subs die ich nicht
gesehen habe dankeschön leute ich gucke noch mal schnell tom tricks vor fünf minuten dankeschön
nice habe ich nicht gesehen gelax war schon am start 19 monate girls glaube alle anderen
habe ich bisher gesehen albino guy habe ich glaube ich übersehen dankeschön vier monats
ab so leute ihr wollt gute nachtlied habe ich gehört das letzte mal wir machen gute
nachtlied weil ihr seid weil ihr seid warum kriege ich das nicht mal vorgeschlagen
ich kriege es nicht mal vorgeschlagen soundtrack da ist es doch also leute wir sehen uns beim
nächsten stream bis dann machts gut